hi in this video I will show how to
count cells in image a and possibly this
is the best method that I could ever
find so I would open an image and first
apply a load or lookup table and I would
apply this fire lookup table because it
give me a good visual it highlights also
that the dark pixels such that I can see
all of the sense so now my objective is
to find how many cells are there now if
I clearly I didn't took a particular
plane to count the cells instead I took
a stack now the reason being simply all
these cells are not in a plane so some
kind in in some cases like cell culture
the cells are like a mono layer on a
plate so in that situation taking one
plane would help but when you are
imaging a whole mount part of a tissue
which has a thickness then cells could
be arranged in several planes so in that
situation taking a single plane won't
help so that's why I would count the
whole stack see in this 3d projection
the cells are actually distributed in
several planes so taking a stack and
Counting throughout the stack could be a
good strategy now since the cells are
clustered here I would draw our way
around it and reposition my car away and
I would simply crop this area for
simplicity now I would count how many
cells are there in this particular
section so in order to do that I will
open my cell counter and the cell
counter plugin comes along with images
so you don't have to download it or
anything so you can directly go to
plug-in analyze and cell counter so once
you click on that a menu would appear
like this so whatever image you have you
have to initialize that image in this
counter so first
select the image and initialize so once
you initialize the image will be there
and you are seeing just a promise tag
that's way okay so after that what we
are going to do is we are going to count
a particular cell type so here I have
only one type of cell so I would just
select type 1 and there are options to
select colors so I will mark everything
in red okay so then what I would do
so let's say it's my whole stack I would
go from each plane and count all the
cells now importantly you have to click
on this show all option on the right
side bottom corner so in this show or
when you press show all then once we
count it would show that counted mark in
throughout all the planes so in the
topmost plane I have nothing to count
because the cells are not visible so I
would go to our stack when I get a
visual of the cells a clear visual of
the cells for example in this stack so
in this stack I would clearly count it
as one I would count it as two and then
I cannot come in anymore so you can see
so maybe I have to change that a duty to
show you that it shows the counting so
when if whenever I go to the plane and
select these cells it would show a field
dot now when I go the plane below that
it would show a black dot so then I
would go again lower and I would mark
these two cell and it is automatically
counting here how many cells I have
counted now it count again and in this
way I would keep on counting but keep on
counting till I finish all of my
counting
so I would keep on counting all the
cells throughout the Zed stack you can
see this cell was pretty not not in same
plane with this cell so if I have to
count it right here for example this
cell this cell if I go down again this
still appeared but it was not there in
previous planes
it was pretty in a pretty deep plane so
I counted then I go down down down and I
don't see any more cells so these are
the my total number of cells you can see
I've counted almost all the cells you
take you see and you see there are total
18 cells and I can get a result so they
have shown that how many cells I have
counted so we can just save this number
or save the result once another good
thing is so we can save the markers so
we can save the markers such that
whenever we want to load it we can load
the image and then do the markers that
that ensures that if I have a counting
mistake any other person when counts can
see which cell I have missed or anything
like that that's why I like this feature
of image a a lot so hope this video was
helpful if you like my video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you